bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 2 juin
coup d'envoi du forum économique
international de saint-pétersbourg des
milliers d'entrepreneurs et de
responsables politiques sont attendus en
russie trois jours de discussions et de
débats pour aborder la situation
économique mondiale post co vide malgré
la pandémie l'événement était maintenue
cette année mais sous contraintes
sanitaires
les agriculteurs bio sont en colère ils
ont manifesté aujourd'hui contre la
réforme de la pac la politique agricole
commune en pleine négociation à
bruxelles
ils redoutent de voir les aides à
l'agriculture biologique baisser avec
les nouveaux arbitrages cette réforme de
la pac doit entrer en vigueur si elle
est adoptée au plus tôt en 2023
[Musique]
emmanuel macron remet en ordre de marche
le président entame un tour de france
passe trop vite dans le lot il
s'achèvera le 14 juillet un bol d'air
dans les territoires qui sonne comme un
avant goût de campagne
de quoi prendre le pouls des français à
moins d'un an de la présidentielle mais
aussi de quoi agacer certains candidats
aux régionales qui eux battent le pavé
[Musique]
il avait été annulée l'année passée en
raison de la pandémie le forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg ouvre
ses portes ce mercredi et jusqu'au 2
juin un forum sous contraintes
sanitaires pendant trois jours
entrepreneurs diplomates ou encore l
responsables politiques vont participer
à des discussions et des débats notre
correspondante verhaeghe hoffman et sur
place plus d'une centaine d'événements
en quatre jours le forum économique de
saint pétersbourg après une pause
l'année dernière due à la pandémie
revient en grande pompe avec comme thème
l'économie de la nouvelle réalité
l'événement phare de la vie économique
russe a dû lui aussi se plier aux
restrictions sanitaires et des
restrictions y en a beaucoup chacun de
5000 participants du forum a dû passer
un test de détection du coronavirus qui
doit être négatif pour activer leur
badge d'entrée partout sur le forum sont
installés des capteurs thermiques qui
bloque les badges des personnes ayant
une température trop élevée
de manière générale nous avons
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus d'expérience
et de ressources pour assurer la
stabilité de la situation
épidémiologique à saint pétersbourg je
suis convaincu que nous serons assurer
la sécurité pendant le forum économique
international de saint pétersbourg la
sécurité pour les participants
comme pour les habitants de la ville
personne ne pourra se rendre au forum
sans test pcr négatif
la carte d'accréditation ne marchera pas
aux postes de passage
le moment fort de ce forum c'est
traditionnellement sa session plénière
cette année y participent le chancelier
autrichien sébastian courte et l'émir du
qatar tamim ben hamad al thani qui
seront en vidéo conférence le président
russe l'a dit mr poutine quant à lui
viendra prendre la parole en personne le
sujet est déterminée par le forum
traditionnellement au forum les discours
porte sur les questions sociales et
économiques
celle du développement social et
économique
du pays de l'attrait des investissements
etc le président est en train de rédiger
son discours devant le forum économique
de saint pétersbourg et le premier forum
d'affaires de grande ampleur à se tenir
en présentiel
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire la
russie est ouverte délégations venues du
monde entier à condition bien sûr que
chacun soit négatif au coronavirus on
n'aurait pas parlé de ce forum organisé
donc tous les enfants la russie nous
retrouvons jean marc sylvestre notre
envoyé spécial sur place à saint
petersbourg
bonsoir jean marc sylvestre merci d'être
avec nous ravie de vous retrouver en
direct sur rt france ce forum maintenu
donc on le disait cette année quels en
sont les enjeux en pleine pandémie
eh bien vous savez ce forum de saint
pétersbourg est considéré dans le monde
entier comme le rival du forum de davos
qui se tient en général dans cette
station suisse et qui rassemble des
milliers de chefs d'entreprises ou de
dirigeants du monde entier
dabo ça a été annulé deux fois de suite
la russie a voulu montrer qu'il fallait
cette année se remettre au travail et
considérer les nouvelles conditions
économiques de la préco vie parce que
saint pétersbourg et bien c'est un forum
de business qui rassemble un certain
nombre d'entreprises
on vient à saint pétersbourg pour
discuter business pour signer des
contrats et pour faire des affaires des
entreprises viennent ici du monde entier
elles viennent de tous les continents
d'asie d'afrique mais aussi d'europe et
même d'amérique en dépit des difficultés
qu'il a pu y avoir au niveau des
rapports entre le reste du monde et la
russie alors avec des conditions et
verra le disais il ya un instant tri
sont très particulières mais je veux
qu'ils officiaient le de russie ont
voulu montré qu'ils étaient capables
d'organiser un forum de cette envergure
dans toutes conditions de sécurité en
protégeant du coc vie d'une façon
peut-être de faire taire un certain
nombre de soupçons qui circulait dans la
communauté nationale selon lequel la
russie avait fait était un peu laxiste
en matière de protection et puis
peut-être aussi en matière de
vaccination alors on le on le sait un
jean-marc on le constate tous les jours
le
russie bashing sur le plan géopolitique
est ce que c'est la même chose dans les
affaires où la communication tout d'un
coup est beaucoup plus fluide quand on
parle business
écoutez ce rocher bassiner est
évidemment présent dans les esprits
n'est présent dans les conversations et
un peu d'eau dans les attitudes ça vous
a pas échappé
ce forum s'ouvre quelques jours après
cette affaire de l'avion de biélorussie
qui a quand même beaucoup refroidi
l'atmosphère internationale ce forum
existe aussi pour montrer de façon très
claire et très précise que d'un côté il
ya la politique avec ses rapports de
force avec ses désaccords avec parfois
ces conflits n'est que de l'autre il y a
des intérêts économiques et je crois que
tous ces participants ici qui sont chefs
d'entreprise banquiers ou parfois
autorités administratives et bien sont
d'accord pour li avec l'idée qu'il faut
protéger les intérêts économiques le
développement parce que c'est un facteur
de progrès et que c'est un facteur de
paix c'est donc à cela qu'ils vont
s'acquitter n'empêche que sur le terrain
politique
on comptait discuter ça peut handicaper
ans parfois la signature les
conversations et économique mais ça
reste de la politique les affaires
économiques sont des affaires beaucoup
plus pragmatique qui mettre en rapport
des gens qui ont envie de travailler
ensemble et on le rappelle un forum qui
se tient alors que la russie doit
toujours à comprendre composer avec un
les sanctions dont elle fait l'objet
alors c'est vrai que les sanctions
planent
la russie doit composer avec ces
sanctions mais ce qui inquiète plus
particulièrement les hommes d'affaires
ici ce sont les menaces les nouvelles
menaces de sanctions consécutives à la
sphère de l'avion de gueule ou russe
c'est vrai que d'un côté comme de
l'autre du côté occidental comme du côté
russe on craint mais sanction qui ce qui
reviendrait si vous voulez a bloqué une
partie notamment des transactions
financières qui sont utilisés dans le
monde aujourd'hui
alors tout le monde pense qu'il faudra
être très prudent là dessus tout le
monde pense que du côté occidental
eh bien ces sanctions sont de la
communication politique peut-être de la
posture notamment de la part de l'europe
qui les a proféré de façon claire mais
que les réponses du président poutine
sont aussi et tout le monde l'a constaté
relativement prenant alors on le
rappelle en pleine pandémie se tient ce
forum les vaccins ou bien encore l'accès
aux médicaments est ce qu'ils sont au
menu de ce forum alors que l'agencé
européenne du médicament doit rendre son
avis prochainement sur les vaccins
russes ethniques
alors absolument absolument vous avez
raison la russie a mis au programme la
question de la santé mondiale et a
programmé notamment un certain nombre de
discussions sur la diffusion au niveau
international des vaccins on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait beaucoup de
coopération dans les échanges entre les
laboratoires sur la connaissance de la
maladie et sur la mise en place d'un
certain nombre de traitements mais on
s'est aussi aperçu des dégâts et à et
alors que les méthodes les diagnostics
ont été particulièrement semblables dans
la plupart des pays du monde on est tous
revenus plus ou moins à des méthodes de
confinement mais la coopération sur les
vaccins s'est avéré beaucoup plus
fragile dès lors qu'il y avait des
intérêts économiques des leurs qui
j'avais intérêt financier c'était la
concurrence et puis aussi il y avait
plus fait des intérêts politiques le
vaccin russe le spoutnik est un produit
d'exportation un produit d'exportation
qui devient très important pour la
russie dans tout pays du monde notamment
l'a fait quand l'amérique du sud et en
asie sauf en europe
vous le disiez parce que l'europe n'a
toujours pas donné son agrément à
l'utilisation du vaccin bus alors virus
sont très vigilants ils sont très
attentifs et sont très impatients sur
cette question parce qu'ils savent que
leur population est assez réticente
aujourd'hui elle a un problème de
confiance envers de la vaccination
et beaucoup d'observateurs se disent ici
que si l'europe venait apporter son
agrément
roscoe skotnik et bien la population
russe ne se vaccinent res de façon plus
volontiers et plus accéléré c'est une
question importante parce que on ne
sortira de cette pandémie que lorsque le
monde entier aura été vaccinées
l'occasion jean marc sylvestre aussi de
s'interroger sur l'état de la
coopération économique franco russe
où en est elle
alors écoutez l'état de la coopération
franco russe elle et elle est plus elle
n'a pas souffert énormément delà de la
situation du pô vide
elle n'a pas trop souffert non plus des
sanctions qui ont été mises en place
elles risqueraient de souffrir en
revanche si les menaces de sanctions qui
ont été proférées était exercée et
aboutissent et à l'exclusion de la
russie du système de financement
internationaux cette coopération franco
russe se traduit par un flux des
échanges importants notamment en gaz et
pétrole on achète beaucoup d'énergie à
la russie le groupe total par exemple
est sans doute allé premier client de la
russie sont d'ailleurs très présents ici
en russie mais pas seulement il ya des
charges au niveau industriel
on a un certain nombre d'investissements
qui sont localisés l'intérêt de la
russie c'est quelque part de sortir un
petit peu du piège de la rente
pétrolière c'est à dire que la une des
activités principales
en termes de produit intérieur brut
c'est évidemment l'exploitation de son
gaz l'exploitation de son pétrole
la russie voudrait évidemment se
diversifier pour se diversifier pour
attirer des investisseurs attirer des
implantations industrielles et c'est un
peu ce à quoi peut servir un forum comme
celui de de saint pétersbourg alors
l'europe l'europe de son côté plus en
vue et la france est un peu j'avais à
dire un peu coincé dans cette affaire
parce que l'europe est partagée par sa
fidélité historique aux états unis après
tout il ya l'otan qui nous protège au
niveau militaire et la proximité
géographique culturelle de la russie
mais ça c'est un peu de politique sur le
terrain économique les choses se passent
beaucoup mieux que sur le terrain
politique
merci beaucoup remarque si vesseron des
règles de saint-pétersbourg
[Musique]
ils sont en colère contre la réforme de
la politique agricole commune les
agriculteurs bio ont manifesté
aujourd'hui partout en france à paris
rendez vous donné à la mi journée place
des invalides le point avec notre
reporter baisse m shelly plus d'une
centaine d'agriculteurs biologiques se
sont donnés rendez vous ici sur la
pelouse des invalides à l'appel de la
fédération nationale de l'agriculture
biologique un rassemblement pacifique
avec beaucoup de prises de paroles
objectif sensibiliser le gouvernement
sur la précarité de leur emploi ils ont
peur de perdre de plus en plus des deux
déjà ils ont noté une baisse de -1 66%
des aides ils ont peur qu'en pleine
négociations de la pac à bruxelles le
gouvernement ainsi que l'union
européenne ne prennent pas en
considération leur situation ici
beaucoup d'inquiétude je vous propose
dans l'écouté certains d'eux qui s'avère
que dans le cadre de cette pac
le ministre de normandie considère
aujourd'hui que il est important de
continuer à une soutenir une agriculture
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui c'est à
dire une agriculture tourner vers
l'agrochimie vers les produits de
synthèse vers les pesticides etc et de
retirer un certain nombre d' aides au
profit de la bio qui est pourtant
plébiscitée par les consommateurs et les
citoyens par avoir un certain nombre d'
avantages qu'elle peut apporter en
termes de qualité de l'eau de
biodiversité de respect des sols etc et
donc face à cette baisse des aides nous
on dénonce cet état de fait
considérant qu aujourd'hui il est
inadmissible qu'on baisse les moyens qui
sont affectés à une bio qui est une
agriculture d'avenir et c'est pour ça
qu'on est là aujourd'hui il ya des gens
parmi les bio qui vont très mal vivre de
leur travail parce qu'aujourd'hui les
prix sont pas suffisamment rémunérateur
et qu'on va c'est pas non plus incitatif
pour les jeunes générations à
s'installer en agriculture biologique
si on vient aussi mais aujourd'hui
manifester c'est parce qu'on voudrait
que ça bouge et que la bio et sa place
en fait à part entière parce que nous
sommes les uns goody
beaucoup de faits remontent obligé de
mettre la paix sur la porte et beaucoup
de paysans comme nous vous êtes obligés
de se mettre au chômage on prête des
agriculteurs biologiques en colère mais
surtout inquiets face à leur avenir
il dénonce un favoritisme fait par
l'union européenne pour les industries
agroalimentaires au détriment des petits
producteurs et j'espère que cette
manifestation pourra alerter le
gouvernement
ils pourront être reçus par le ministre
de la culture monsieur de normandie afin
de pouvoir expliquer leur situation et
que le gouvernement puisse enfin les
écouter et répondre favorablement à leur
situation ils déclarent vouloir sauver
leur emploi et sauver une agriculture
plus verte et plus responsable et il
faut en parler nous sommes avec l'un
d'entre eux jérôme quévert président
délégué de la fédération régionale
d'agriculture biologique de nouvelles
l'aquitaine bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous nouvelles manifestations dont on le
disait avec beth chimie une baisse
d'environ 66% des aides
c'est ce que vous craignez pourquoi ces
baisses pourquoi si le vc c'est très
facile à expliquer on avait actuellement
dans les bacs actuels d'eads au
verdissement qu'à peu près tous les
agriculteurs touchent et environ 132
euros en moyenne pour toutes les
productions a reçu en moyenne sur toute
la france par hectare ld qu'on appelait
des lots maintien pour victor qui est
telle en bio donc on était à plus de 200
euros 210 euros d aides à l'hectare pour
la bio est là le gouvernement a proposé
que les led pour les arrivées tordu à
60,10 euros par hectare donc si on fait
le calcul on a une baisse de 66% des
aides à l'hectare pour l'ensemble des
producteurs view de france ça semble
être géré en colère quand on vous écoute
tout simplement une volte face parce que
vous dites voilà il ya une baisse mais
on
seul explique pas vraiment d'autant
qu'on est souvent me tuer à des messages
qui encourage consommateurs français à
bien manger donc pourquoi cette espèce
de revirement de la part du gouvernement
le revirement du gouvernement c'est
merci à alain fluence du syndicat
majoritaire la fnsea qui compte un coup
au nord de l'écossé
c'est à dire aux lentilles vertes du de
la nouvelle pac aille à la majorité des
agriculteurs et pour cela les cultures
ou mieux traités au même niveau que le
hce qui est donc un label de haute
valeur environnementale mais qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec le bio parce
que avec la jeu on peut utiliser des
pesticides utilisés les engrais
chimiques et les les
les conséquences pour l'environnement
sont bien moindres que ce qu'apporte
j'avais culture bio avec des
conséquences on imagine également
négative sur le consommateur puisqu'il y
aura forcément une répercussion des prix
et le consommateur pourra peut-être
mangé ce que ce que notre revendication
elle porte sur une chose très simple
c'est de dire que l'agriculture
l'agriculteur y produit de la nourriture
pour les consommateurs et l'agriculture
bio en même temps par semaine qu'il fait
il protège eu un certain nombre de biens
communs qui sont l'eau la biodiversité
le climat et que c'est bien commun ils
doivent être rémunérés par l'ensemble de
la société et donc par les aides
donc nous c'est pas des aides pour
economics et dz par rapport à notre
travail pour qu'on reconnaisse la
qualité du travail qu'on fait par
rapport à l'environnement
et si ya pas d'elle forcément on va
répercuter cette part qui est sociale
collective sur les produits avec des
conséquences sur la cherté des produits
la capacité de pouvoir développer ses
produits vers la restauration collective
favoriser l'importation de produits de
pays tiers etc etc
voilà le président je vous en prie le
président de la république un fait en ce
moment bardon et son tour de france pour
aller au plus près des citoyens
provinciaux dit il qu'il connaît moi
vous dit également que son arrivée au
pouvoir a sonné la fin du développement
de l'agriculture biologique
pour quelles raisons la raison est
simple c'est que en fait jusqu'à présent
la une thèmes biologique était soutenu
par de financement de l'état en
particulier et aussi des rayons et quand
il est arrivé en 2017 il a supprimé la
part de l'état sur l'aide au maintien
led qui permet d'ailleurs qui jouent
depuis plusieurs années
alors d'où une nouvelle aquitaine on a
eu beaucoup de chance on a travaillé
très bien avec région nouvelle aquitaine
parce que à l'époque ces aides a été
distribué région donc notre région a
pris la parole à a et à compenser la pta
pour que l'ensemble des paysans bio de
nouvelles aquitaine est une ado maintien
jusqu'à la fin de cette pac mais mais le
président macro n'a fait aucun effort
pour en développer la pac dans sa
politique eric vous avez clairement
l'impression aujourd'hui qu'on vous
punit au détriment peut-être de ceux qui
travaillent avec deux plus mauvaises
pratiques agricoles c'est vers cette
tendance tas je sais pas si on peut
entre les émissions je pense que moi je
suis redoux depuis plus de 25 ans et
j'ai le sentiment depuis très longtemps
que l'agriculture biologique fait peur à
un certain non à une frange
d'agriculteurs et de développent de
développeurs à l'école d'agrochimie qui
ne sont pas capables de faire face à
notre technicité à notre façon de
produire à notre façon de voir le vivant
à notre façon de considérer le bien-être
mal à notre façon de faire attention à
l'université à l'environnement et
effectivement il ya une pression
extrêmement fortes contre ce mode
ce mode agricole tout une chaire
économique mais par contre on a la
chance d'avoir à côté de nous des
consommateurs qui nous plébiscite des
territoires qui nous plébiscite qui se
rendent bien compte que l'agriculture
biologique c'est une solution pour le
traitement de l'eau pour tous tout une
bonne transition agricole qui devient
nécessaire
merci d'avoir été avec nous gérons
clairement savoir à exposer vos
revendications en direct sur arte france
et direction lyon à présent faute de
places dans les centres d'hébergement
des sans papiers mineurs ont investi un
parc public depuis vendredi dernier en
attendant de trouver une solution avec
lé service de la métropole
plusieurs associations se mobilisent
pour leur venir en aide
luis carballo avec antoine ogier un
jardin transformé en campement de
fortune pour accueillir une vingtaine de
migrants principalement originaires
d'afrique sub saharienne et
d'afghanistan
expulsé depuis mi mai de leurs centres
d'hébergement ces jeunes qui se disent
âgés de 16 à 17 ans parviennent à
survivre grâce au soutien de plusieurs
associations
il ya pas mal de temps qui ont été
donnés également par des voisins qui
nous apporte des duvets
des matelas du matériel de camping des
lampes frontales pour qu'on soit le
mieux possible dans ces espaces même si
c'est évidemment loin d'être idéale mais
avant le maximum de confort et dons
obtenus en partie grâce à des listes de
besoins publié sur facebook mais aussi à
travers une sensibilisation auprès des
habitants de la ville qui passe dans le
square un appel au soutien dans
l'ensemble bien perçue par le voisinage
il ya plein bois de la qui prennent des
gars pour les emmener doucher chez nous
et puis qui prennent du linge sale pour
faire des lessives que ici c'est un peu
rudimentaire quand même aider vu la
façon dont ils sont accueillis il faut
bien que le citoyen aide quand même
les services de la métropole de lyon qui
ont débloqué une cinquantaine de places
supplémentaires pour les mineurs isolés
dans le dispositif d'hébergement
d'urgence ont estimé après une procédure
officielle que ces jeunes n'étaient pas
mineures et les ont donc expulsé dehors
centres d'accueil une décision contestée
qui pourrait bien prendre jusqu'à huit
mois avant d'être réexaminés
plus rapidement possible de trouver des
solutions de relogement donc on
s'adresse à la métropole à la préfecture
pour essayer de trouver des solutions
ensemble pour reloger ces mineurs qui
sont en attente de reconnaissance dont
qui sont en cours de procédures pour
lesquelles donc il ya besoin d'une vraie
prise en charge un accompagnement sur
l'hébergement sur l'alimentation sur les
transports en attendant une décision des
services de la métropole
les associations continue d'alerter sur
l'état de santé physique et mentale de
ces jeunes forcés de vivre dans la rue
avec tous les risques d'agression que
cela comprend rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons du tour
de france présidentiel à moins d'un an
de l'élection présidentielle emmanuel
macron part à la rencontre de ses
électeurs
un moment bien choisi juste avant les
régionales c'est une question que l'on
se pose nous décrypterons cela avec nos
invités
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station mir ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba et là on
est alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tous les soucis sont toutes les
décroissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne savent pas je ne pensais
jamais de ma vie faire la plonge ans et
demi vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui ait des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative au
sens du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
en octobre 2020 l'exécutif européen a
présenté une directive relative à des
salaires minimaux adéquat dans l'union
européenne
objectif combattre la pauvreté chacun
des pays européens est face à une montée
des inégalités et à est limité très
violente de la pauvreté et l exclusion
on est en train de s'occuper d'un
salaire minimum alors que le problème
c'est deux fois déjà trouvé un moyen
pour faire baisser le chômage parce que
les chômeurs ils s'en fichent du salaire
minimum ils n'ont pas de travail donc
ils n'ont pas de salaire bouna un
problème de développement économique il
s'agit pas d'imposer ans micka dpi
tuerait pas les moyens tout simplement
d'y faire face
vous avez quand même pas mal d'études
qui ont été faites justement sur le smic
en disant que le tweak écartés du marché
du travail les gens peu qualifiés qu'on
peut se poser aussi la question de
savoir si réellement c'est une bonne
idée
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés et qui
sont montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise ces firmes
mais comment peuvent-ils mentir comme
des arracheurs de dents à ce point
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur arte france si
vous nous rejoignez manuel macron se
remet en ordre de marche le président
entame un tour de france post comines
dans le lot
de quoi prendre le pouls des français à
moins d'un an de la présidentielle pour
plus de précision on retrouve david
kelly fa en direct de l'elysée bonsoir
david alors cette tournée en province un
interroge évidemment il est français ne
sont pas forcément convaincu l'accueil
est plutôt mitigé pour le moment
effectivement cette famille à 18 jours
des élections régionales et
départementales l'opposition pointe du
doigt un coup de com' médiatique de la
part d' emmanuel macron emmanuel macron
qui souhaite renouer le dialogue avec
les français pour cela il a choisi un
endroit qu'il connaît plutôt bien
saint cyr lapopie est un village
médiéval qu'il a déjà visité trois fois
depuis le début de son quinquennat le
chef d'état et est apprécié par les
habitants qui espère redonner un coup de
fouet au tourisme avec cette visite
c'est d'ailleurs sur ça qu'il a insisté
lors de son discours
emmanuel macron et malgré cette
sympathie affichée par les commerçants
par les restaurateurs et ses bains de
foule qu'on a pu apercevoir un lors de
cette visite des manuels macro et bien
l'accueil était plutôt mitigé voire un
peu plus hostiles pour le chef de l'état
français aux alentours de saint cyr
lapopie puisque plusieurs mobilisations
contre la politique ce sont contre la
politique du chef d'état se sont tenues
notamment un rassemblement à
l'initiative de la confédération
paysanne
à 46 ans qui dénoncent les coupes
budgétaires les suppressions d'emplois
l'inaction l'inaction climatique et les
lois liberticides mais aussi pour
soutenir les postiers en grève à gramat
un lieu de 200 rassemblements non loin
de saint cirq lapopie tous les moyens
ont été mis en place pour éviter à des
débordements à titre d'exemple pierre
dufour le porte parole de cette même
confédération paysanne avec 46 a vu son
compte facebook bloqué lorsque ce qu'il
a lancée elle appelle à cette
mobilisation écouter
on sait qu'à saint cirq lapopie il sera
impossible de se rassembler c'est
pourquoi on improvise cette mobilisation
à gramat sur le rond-point des gilet
jaune route de saint céré l'objectif
n'est pas de mettre le bordel mais
d'avoir une visibilité médiatique au
niveau national puisque emmanuel macron
a envie de converser avec les gens il
est invité à le faire avec nous à gramat
pourparlers avec les postiers en grève
nous voulons dire à macron qu'il ne nous
fera pas taire
alors évidemment il manuellement qu'on
n'a pas fait le détour un parent crama
un dispositif de sécurité conséquent est
plutôt impressionnant été mise en place
un hélicoptère des barrages filtrants un
des gendarmes et des crs déployés quand
on arrive en terrain conquis
ce n'est pas forcément un signe de
confiance flagrant en tout cas dans ce
village médiéval elle de saint cyr
lapopie ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
emmanuel macron l'opération séduction
des manuels macron pour retrouver sa
place ici même à l'élysée en 2022 et
bien non clencher ch et david c'est
essentiellement ce qui a été reproché
par la classe politique
emmanuel macron dénonce notamment de
l'hypocrisie
oui stéphanie de la part de la classe
politique mais aussi de la part des
français qui étaient plutôt dubitatif
quant à cette tournée en province du
côté de toulouse on estime qu'il est
trop tard pour pouvoir s'adresser aux
français écoutent et oui je pense que
c'est un peu sa manière à lui de montrer
qu'il est là un peu partout ça permet
justement à ces territoires qui sont
moins touchés par la politique de se
remobiliser et de montrer qu'il il porte
un intérêt donc pourquoi pas toucher des
potentiels électeurs
oui je pense qu'il commence sa campagne
électorale le fait justement qu'il aille
un petit peu voir tout le monde qu'il
sorte de sa réserve
je pense que c'est le moment que de
toute façon parce que les élections sont
dans dans combien de temps
dans moins de nom s'ils se baladent
partout c'est pour pouvoir voir un peu
le peuple et essayer de gagner des
points partout donc je pense oui
il aurait dû le faire avant je pense
après c'est peut-être un peu trop tard
mais oui il vaut mieux plus de faim tard
que jamais mais il aurait peut-être dû
le faire avant
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes ont
manifesté leur mécontement
mécontentement pardon contre sa
politique et que maintenant monsieur
essaye de faire le petit père des
peuples
on a en commençant par le lot et en
finissant peut-être par l'ardèche c'est
pas comme ça qu'il y aura des oies dans
la mesure où déjà au niveau des
régionales c'est pour moi très mal parti
pour lui des réactions mitigées à les
politiques sont un peu plus tranchant de
leur côté les républicains
elle pointe du doigt un manque de
sincérité une mise en scène pour
aurélien pradié députés aient l'air du
lot 1 chez nos confrères de france info
florian philippot leader des patriotes
est plus tranchant sur twitter et accuse
macron d'utiliser l'argent du
contribuable pour financer sa campagne
régionales et présidentielle à gilbert
collard parle de cirque pour un
président qui lance sa précampagne
présidentielle
même son cloche pour alexis corbière un
député de la france insoumise et valérie
pécresse à la présidente de la région
ile de france se dit même choqué par le
fait que ce tour de france commence à
trois semaines d'une élection et pendant
la période de réserve politique
de qualif en direct de l'elysée emmanuel
macron qui donc entament cette grande
tournée un tour de france pour renouer
le contact avec la population à moins
d'un an de la présidentielle on le
disait une opération de communication
rondement mené mais qui laisse cependant
percevoir des failles c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soit avec nous pour
en parler jérôme rodriguez j des jaunes
bonsoir jérôme rodriguez merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire enfin alexis poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir à tous les trois
merci d'être là on l'a vu à la terrasse
d'un café pour la réouverture des
terrasses là c'est dans le lot pour
marquer la séquence retour à la vie
normale des français opération séduction
opération communication clairement
arnaud benedetti le président est parti
en reconquête électorale
en bas il est clairement disons ont pré
campagne présidentielle
mais vous savez c'est un président de la
république qui a vu son mandat au fonds
dément perturbé par différents
événements une crise sociale sans
précédent ces dix dernières années va
quitter gilet jaune une crise sanitaire
tout à fait exceptionnelle et qui
vraisemblablement considère que la
promesse initiale qui était la sienne a
été d'une certaine manière bien
profondément perturbé par ces événements
donc il renoue avec eux les figures qui
est une cyber originel du maquereau nice
vous savez c'est la marche être en
marche
l'itinérance aller à la rencontre des
gens c'est ce qu'il avait fait en 2016
et en 2017 c'est ce qu'il a essayé de
faire en faisant ce fameux tour de
france en 2018 et 2019 au moment de la
crise des gilet jaune et il pense que ça
lui réussit donc ça en tout cas c'est
vraisemblablement ce qu'il ya derrière
en tout cas cette idée de tour de france
le problème c'est que aujourd'hui il est
quand même confronté à une réalité qui
est une réalité sociale une réalité
politique les réalités économiques
en ce qui est profondément fracturé
est-ce que cet exercice de communication
qui apparaîtra certains assez artificiel
va être en mesure d'une certaine manière
de renouer avec d'un côté des catégories
populaires et on sait très bien que de
ce côté-là il a quand même quelques
difficultés en termes de relations
politiques et avec la france notamment
la france des terroirs
on sait aussi pertinemment que la
république en marche et que le maquereau
nisme 11 zones rurales e rencontres ou
das un certain nombre de difficultés
c'est certainement l'objectif qui
poursuit mais bon l'avenir nous dira si
d'une certaine manière cette cette
entreprise atteint sa cible
emmanuel macron le pari de la campagne
permanente ans est ce que titrait le
figaro aujourd'hui c'est ce que ça vous
inspire aussi l ex époux là oui c'est
exactement ça on a là une présidence qui
fait un tour potemkine de france il va
aller voir les villages où l'élu local
est pro macro nist où il était né il va
privatiser le village là il choisit un
petit village de moins de 2 500
habitants
les habitants sont coincés chez eux
pendant 48 heures il ya autant de crs
quasiment que d'habitants il se met en
scène devant un fond vert un peu ce côté
la france tranquille on a l'impression
que il veut absolument faire terroir
donc c'est très joli de voir un peu de
feuillages derrière lui il pourrait
faire ça devant un fond vert dans les
jardins de l'elysée ça ferait pas il y
aurait moins de dépenses de sécurité qui
seraient mises en place clairement on
est en train de voir ce que fait mairie
de mâcon c'est à dire de l' influence
perpétuelle de la propagande aussi
puisque c'est de la propagande old
school vraiment à l'ancienne on a là on
parler de petit père des peuples c'est
vraiment ça le côté le roi descend du
palais pour aller voir son peuple et
voir un peu comment ça va or si tout ça
est mise en scène on a affaire à des
gens triés sur le volet sans doute les
lecteurs
de la république en marche la femme du
président avec un cordon de sécurité qui
empêche d'aller voir ce qui manifeste
quelques kilomètres plus loin pour le
dire mais venez voir la france la vraie
celle que vous ne voulez pas voir celle
qui est derrière ce décor en carton que
vous proposer à tous les jt de 20h à
quelques kilomètres de là à rodez c'est
l'usiné bosch qui va fermer c'est
renault qui t'aiment des usines dans la
région c'est un hôpital en souffrance à
quelques km également
et le voir pérorer de cette façon-là
parler aux français de manière
condescendante idiote en disant qu'ils
on pourra prendre des vacances cet été
et que faire de ces milliers de français
de ces millions de français qui vont
tomber dans la précarité qui n'ont pas
d'argent pour se payer des vacances rien
du tout aucun mot pour cela par contre
il est en terrasse et il parle des jours
heureux
les jours heureux ce sera quand il n'y
aura plus de confinement quand il n'y
aura plus de ces politiques antisociales
de casse de la république sociale qu'il
met en place sous couvert de
dépolitisation du débat parce que ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui et c'est une
pantomime c'est simplement faire croire
que ce président à la main sur une crise
sanitaire qu'il a très mal géré et que
son bilan est tout à fait défendable
il ne l'est pas même ce président
réformateur n'a pas fait passer les
réformes pour lesquelles il avait soi
disant été élu que ce soit la réforme
des retraites ou le reste il a bien du
mal en réalité donc on a des cartes
postales et cette marche
cette mise en scène du corps du roi
c'est à peu près ça va servir de
propagande dans la campagne des
régionales puisque les ministres eux
sont tenus au silence par la loi le
voilà qui va aller à amiens par exemple
avant une grande fête pour pousser les
candidats de la république en marche
c'est scandaleux
tout ça avec bien sûr nos impôts et la
stature présidentielle qui lui permet
d'enjamber finalement le débat
effectivement alexis c'est c'était le
sens de plusieurs commentaires
politiques aujourd'hui je vous propose
devant de faire réagir jérôme rodriguez
écoutez la réaction d'aurélien pradié
le député les républicains du linge
justement le président de la république
a une fâcheuse et permanente tendance à
prendre les français pour des imbéciles
tout le monde est lucide il vient faire
campagne ça me dérange parce que dans
une république bien organisé le mélange
des genres n'est jamais bon monsieur
macro aurait pu comme d'autres
présidents de la république l'ont fait
s'abstenir pendant trois semaines laissé
les français et ne pas utiliser les
moyens de l'état et ceux de la
république pour venir faire campagne
jérôme rodriguez c'est vrai qu'on lui a
souvent reproché son arrogance à
emmanuel macron lui reprocherait
peut-être de rester dans son palais de
l'elysée c'est forcément prendre les
français pour des imbéciles que d'aller
à leur contact
mais mais mais complètement on est
complètement pris pour des imbéciles
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui s'offusque
sur le fait que les l'argent du
contribuable soit mise aux dépens du
président de la république pour pouvoir
mener campagne
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on connaît
depuis des années et ça fait 40 ans que
ça dure chaque président qu'il veut se
faire réélire va utiliser son mandat de
président pour se faire réélire et
forcément l'argent des français pour
cela moi c'est pas ça qui me choque le
plus parce que c'est quelque chose qui
passe est choquant depuis ce chantier de
ça parce que ça existe depuis des
dizaines d'années en tout cas que ça
existe depuis que moi je suis né moi ce
qui me choque le plus c'est qu'il part à
la rencontre des français et que ça va
coûter encore une blonde alors que c'est
pas faute d'avoir essayé nous d'aller à
sa rencontre
je vous rappelle que nous les jeunes
étions à 100 mètres de l'elysée et qui à
défaut d'avoir été reçus nous avons été
reçus à coups de mutilation
verbalisation j'en passe et des
meilleurs donc aujourd'hui il a bonne
mine le garçon de vouloir faire le tour
de la france pour aller à la rencontre
des français quand on voit que ne
serait-ce que la dernière personne en
date à qui je vais faire référence qui
s'appellent sandrine c'est la dernière
gilet jaune qu'il a pu rencontrer au
salon de l'agriculture et qu'il avait
promis un rendez vous à l'elysée quand
on lui a donné la liste des noms fin de
non recevoir
donc s'il veut aller à la rencontre des
français je l'invite à venir le samedi
après-midi peut-être manifester avec les
gilets jaunes je l'invite à venir
manifester les mardis et les jeudis avec
lady fait différentes corporations aux
différents métiers qui manifestent
depuis maintenant trois ans et force est
de constater qu'à défaut de pouvoir
entendre l'ensemble des doléances depuis
son palais il préfère sortir la matraque
et la répression
donc on n'est encore sûr voilà on
encore sûr de la politique spectacle du
duo on est sûr que l'instinct g on est
sûr de la d'assurance on est là on vient
faire le beau gosse moi je me rappelle
que sur la vidéo où on le voit faire des
galipettes sur la pelouse de l'elysée
quand vous voyez les commentaires des
jeunes qui ont commandé or il est trop
beau serra beaux gosses non on n'est pas
là pour faire des beaux gosses il a mis
aujourd'hui la jeunesse dans la merde et
je pèse mes mots est allé à la rencontre
les français c'est vraiment les prendre
pour des imbéciles moi j'ai eu contact
avec leurs points gilet jaune de gramat
qui avaient prévu d'aller à la rencontre
du président macron au vu du protocole
et de la du dispositif policier ils
n'ont pas pu avoir accès donc quels sont
les français qu'aujourd'hui moi la
question je me pose quels sont les
français aujourd'hui que monsieur mac on
va rencontrer
alors du côté de la majorité en tous cas
c'est un autre discours 1 puisque
évidemment on applaudit cette initiative
présidentielle
aller au contact des français c'est le
cas de marc fesneau le ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne écoutez moi je
pense que c'était un intérêt pour le
président de la république et pour ceux
qui les rencontrent de pouvoir échanger
sur les sujets du moment
il y a toujours un intérêt à aller sur
le terrain et rencontrer des gens
je pense que le président a toujours été
à l'écouté des territoires carnot
benedetti a toujours un intérêt à aller
sur le terrain on a vu quand même il
faut le rappeler en cette campagne
présidentielle que savait extrêmement
bien réussi à emmanuel macron qui n'est
pas mauvais dans cet exercice il avait
un regard un gars disais pas mal de de
vieux politiciens en tout cas sur le
terrain lors de la campagne c'est
peut-être même ce qu'il avait fait
gagner est ce qu il peut recoller avec
les français dans cet exercice
non ce qui l'a fait gagner ce sont des
circonstances absolument exceptionnel
d'enjeu politique bien plus que sa
stratégie de communication même si sa
stratégie de communication a
certainement aidé à un moment donné à
donner le coup de rein final pour qu'il
puisse l'emporter mais s'ils voulaient
le la réalité aujourd'hui
pour emmanuel macron c'est que à la
différence de toutes façons de 2016 et
2017 c'est que aujourd'hui il est
important et il est important à et que
un bilan à défendre et on voit bien que
aujourd'hui
ce qui est en jeu bien évidemment c'est
là l'illustration et la défendre ce
bilan alors si on se met du côté
finalement de ses partisans et de la
sociologie qui l'a soutenu même cette
sociologie pu être d'une certaine
manière déçu par ce bilan tout
simplement parce que il n'est pas allé
jusqu'au bout des réformes qu'il avait
dû promettre qu'il avait promis aux
françaises et aux français
bah on voit bien que ce qui s'est passé
avec la crise sanitaire notamment mais
également avec la crise les gilet jaune
ça a été quand même une remise en
question radicale du logiciel initiale
des manuels macron parce que qu'est-ce
qui fonctionne aujourd'hui dans cette
crise sanitaire finalement c'est l'état
providence auquel malgré tout sa
politique souhaité s'attaquer si on peut
encore redistribuer tel qu'on le fait
notamment en à destination des
entreprises en difficulté c'est parce
que cet état providence existe donc
quelque part il a quasiment la tradi la
traduction
j'allais dire presque en direct deux de
la limite de sa de sa politique de
réforme et puis ensuite et bien
évidemment du côté d'une grande partie
de ses opposants de droite comme de
gauche
on voit bien que il y a un bilan qui est
contestée parce qu'on considère que
c'est un président de la république qui
loin d'avoir réuni le pays l'a
vraisemblablement encore plus archi
lisez qu'il ne l'était en 2010 est donc
il efface aujourd'hui à quelques parades
et à des lignes de fronts multiples et
finalement son objectif c'est quoi son
objectif politique immédiat c'est
d'abord de tenir la sociologie
électorale qui lui a permis d'être élu
en 2017 et qui lui a permis notamment
par exemple aux dernières élections
européennes d'avoir une liste qui
finalement a ri la touche touche avec le
rassemblement national son deuxième
objectif c'est d'essayer d'ouvrir un
front électoral vert de manière très
segmenté de manière très marketé alors
un jour il va s'adresser aux jeunes
parce que il considère que dans la
tranche d'âge 18 24 ans ils bénéficient
d'un capital confiance
encore faut-il que ce capital confiance
eux retranscrivant capital électoral ce
qui est ce qui n'est pas fait alors
aujourd'hui
il va dans le lointain alors le lot
c'est très symbolique en plus qu'est-ce
qui avec quoi il veut renouer
il veut renouer avec ce qu'on appelle la
république des terroirs la république et
au village le lot c'est une tradition
républicaine radical socialiste c'est
une tradition qui est très éloignée de
son logiciel politique et de son
logiciel communicants de 2017 qui
étaient les logiciels de la start up
nation
ils essayent finalement de rattraper le
retard sur un certain nombre de segments
les jeunes qui ont eu à souffrir
notamment de la crise sanitaire les
territoires ruraux qui l'a finalement
assez peu entendu les territoires les
élus territoriaux
on va perdre on va essayer distribuer la
parole sinon voilà malheureusement on
n'arrivera pas tous vous faire parler
mais alex et poulain c'est vrai qu'on
lui a souvent reproché à cette posture
aussi de président des riches et mais
des macros soutenu par 41% des électeurs
et 41 % d'entre eux se disent à gauche
contre 35% seulement à droite ça dit
quoi c'est qu'il est c'est un petit peu
rattrapé sur cette image de président
voilà des est des privilégiés des plus
aisés le bon pied de rothschild non
c'est simplement soupire mme rodrigues
m'a fait pas les gros bras vous que vous
donnez la parole dit simplement que les
sondages font partie de cet outil de
propagande qui est mise en place et je
parle de propagande à dessin c'est
vraiment on est là dans une
communication politique organisée pour
faire croire quesnel macro et leur même
temps est un succès qu'il reste de
gauche alors qu'il fait la course à
l'échalote avec marine le pen sur des
thèmes de droite qu'il a perdu son aile
gauche depuis très très longtemps et
donc évidemment avec les budgets qui
sont alloués par matignon et autres aux
instituts de sondage qui continue on a
l'impression que même la crau est
toujours entre 33 et 40 % mais ça fait
60 % d'insatisfaits et sur les électeurs
de gauche
évidemment qu'ils aient une centre une
partie de centre gauche qui va rester
fidèle à un grand temps que si jamais il
est face à une marine le pen on votera
bien sûr emmanuel macron pour faire
barrage mais ceux là sont de moins en
moins nombreux parce que la plupart des
électeurs de gauche qui avaient pu jouer
le jeu en 2017 ont totalement décrochés
et aujourd'hui cet exercice de
communication il n'a qu'un seul but
dépolitiser absolument le débat que ce
soit avec les youtuber sur tik tok
maintenant dans cette mise en scène
parce que c'est une mise en scène c'est
ce tour de france qu'il organise ils
privatisent des villages des pans
entiers pour se mettre en scène avec des
gens qui vont écouter sa bonne parole
exactement ce qu'il avait fait avec le
grand débat pour clore les finalement
les cahiers de doléances des gilets
jaunes qui n'ont jamais été entendus
ceux là sont enterrés dans les sous-sols
de la bnf
donc c'est encore une entourloupe macro
nist comme il l'a fait en 2017 pour son
élection avec la grande marche soit
disant qu'ils devaient accepter au
classement ce que les français
attendaient puis avec ce grand débat qui
était la campagne des européennes
et maintenant voilà qui lance sa
campagne pour l'élection présidentielle
de 2000 22 avec ce tour de france en
touristes pour le plan france relance
qui est un plan macro relance en réalité
avec l'argent européen avec des
milliards qui sont mis en jeu pour faire
croire que ce président à sauver la
france de la crise ducobu d'alors qui
lui a mis la tête sous l'eau avec des
confinement des couvre feux et des
secteurs entiers de l'économie qui ont
été obligés de fermer alors
effectivement sauf qu'il ya eu quand
même comme le souligne arnaud benedetti
de l'état providence dépendent de
l'économie ont quand même tenu par
rapport à d'air aux états unis je vous
invite m a regardé la situation aux
états unis dans les rues avec les
multiplications des des sdf une
stratégie vaccinale qui semble peut-être
par moment faire peut-être oublié les
couacs du passé jérôme rodriguez c'est
ses arguments est ce qu'ils peuvent
faire mouche pour vous mais à la maison
il est est ce que vous pensez que vous
craignez puisque vous n'êtes pas un
partisan du manuel macron c'est pas
secret ce que vous craignez que ça
puisse leur acheter manuel macron et que
eh bien ça marche une seconde fois
l'état providence mais à un moment donné
ce pognon va falloir le rembourser les
180 milliards d'euros mis sur la table
va falloir qu'on les rembourse
moi depuis que je suis née je connais
pas d'argent gratuit c'est pas possible
un moment donné il faut on ne parle
d'état providence
on va venir nous on va venir se servir
dans nos poches on va venir se servir
dans les poches de nos enfants donc
autant dire que la misère allemand
encore s'accumuler encore plus longue
l'état providentiel je rejoins monsieur
bédié dit il n'y a pas de souci mais cet
argent la fois par leur bon c'est tout
talent je reprends aussi en termes de
monsieur benedetti qui disait qu'il est
confronté à des crises sociales
il n'est pas confronté à des crises
sociales il est créateur de ses clips
social aujourd'hui parce qu'il a il a
aujourd'hui rompue l'ensemble des liens
sociaux qui pouvait y avoir il a rompu
aussi les liens qui pouvait y avoir à la
avec la politique
et si je reprends les termes de mon ami
monsieur poulin quand on nous dit
politique spectacle c'est exactement ça
aujourd'hui on est on a fait en sorte de
désastre uire de désintéresser
l'ensemble des français sur des sujets
de politique au sens noble du terme
on est là aux parades dans des villages
ont fait le bout dans des villes sans
forcément se concentrer sur la majeure
partie des français aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont un souci et je le répète je reprend
les termes d'un d'un film le plus dur
c'est pas la chute c'est l'atterrissage
et je vous garantis qu'à des gens qui
vont atterrir et vont avoir très mal
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui moi je me
méfie des sondages parce que sincèrement
alors on va dire oui jérôme il est pas
pour mâcon forcément mais moi quand je
me balade dans la rue que j'aille chez
mon fruitiers que j'aille au tabac que
j'aille au magasin je rencontre des
commerciaux devront des coudes et des
courtiers enfin je rencontre des gens
qui sont potentiellement électeurs de
macron pour la moitié ce sont des cocus
et pour l'autre moitié il ne veut plus
en entendre parler et c'est ça la
réalité c'est pour ça que moi je me me
pose la question avec ses ces sondages
aujourd'hui convoi qui font le jeu au
final de maquereaux et qui font aussi le
jeu de madame le pen pour toujours et
encore une fois attiré les français sur
un deuxième tour kiki que les vents
c'est que les français ne veulent plus
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que moi
j'essaie de monter un front aujourd'hui
que pour au premier tour ni le pen ni
macron parce que moi je vais pas voter
pour quelqu'un qui est fasciste et je
vais pas voter pour quelqu'un qui m'a
crevé un oeil ça c'est une certitude
donc aujourd'hui à nous électeurs un
nous aujourd'hui de récupérer la
politique au sens noble du terme
et s'il faut au premier tour votons pour
une chaîne elle fera beaucoup mieux que
toutes ces personnes là aujourd'hui qui
met à mal la france
donc en gros vous n'en attendait plus
rien d'ici mai 2022 d'emmanuel mhz écran
géant mme rodrigues quand vous comprends
bien mais ça fait deux ans et demi qu'on
est dans la rue ça fait deux ans et demi
qu'on a des propositions à faire ça fait
deux ans et demi que vous avez des
groupes de travail gilet jaune comme le
gouffre comme le syndicat gilet jaune
vous savez qu'il ya un syndicat gillet
jour d'aujourd'hui qui a réussi à
s'implanter chez amazon qui a réussi à
s'implanter à la fnac qui a réussi à
s'implanter à carrefour market
on n'entend pas parler alors on était là
à pous tio nez sur les gilets jaunes en
dix ans votre manque d'organisation vous
ne savez pas quoi faire vous ne savez
pas quoi dire mais là à défaut de parler
de violence dans les manifestations je
vous garantis qu'il ya un boulot énorme
qui a été fabriqué aujourd'hui on serait
accapare la politique et on va être
actif pendant l'année présidentielle
pour faire en sorte que macro excusez
moi du terme dégage du milieu politique
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin de gens
compétents et la compétence va se
retirer au niveau des citoyens sur une
démocratie directe et participative pour
que l'ensemble des français puisse avoir
la parole au long des cinq ans et non
pas attendre le jour j d'une élection
présidentielle en faisant semblant de
leur donner une voix et de leur demander
de la fermer pendant cinq ans à coups de
matraque de l bd de gazeuse ou de
verbalisation merci merci à tous les
trois jérôme rodriguez arnaud benedetti
alexis poulain d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce décryptage
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur le forum économique
de saint-pétersbourg qui s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui en russie
milliers d'entrepreneurs et de
responsables politiques sont attendus
sur place
et puis direction ils seraient les
opposants benyamin nétanyahou ont
jusqu'à minuit pour tenter de former une
coalition
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du long vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station milliards ou
la station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
si demain un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser il se déroulera dans la
mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux du saint
en 2019 la chine a construit en une
année tombe peu plus de bâtiments que
les états unis en quatre en guerre de
1941 à 1945 en affichant ainsi sa
souveraineté en mer de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits dits
historiques sur les règles
internationales dont une puissance
dominante constate qu'elle est en train
de se faire dépasser par une puissance
émergente la tentation normale et de la
détruire au plan politique ou militaire
avant qu'elle n'arrive à ses fins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous appelons des
pratiques professionnelles protectrice
la justice à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 2 juin
coup d'envoi du forum économique
international de saint-pétersbourg des
milliers d'entrepreneurs et responsables
politiques sont attendus en russie trois
jours de discussions et de débats pour
aborder la situation économique mondiale
post co vide malgré la pandémie
l'événement était maintenue cette année
mais sous conditions et contraintes
sanitaires les opposants mallet me
netanyahu ont jusqu'à minuit pour se
mettre d'accord négociations entre la
gauche le centre de yaïr lapid et une
partie de la droite dont la formation de
l'aft ali bennett chef de file de la
droite radicale
il pourrait devenir le futur premier
ministre d'israël hasard du calendrier
c'est aujourd'hui que le travailliste
yitzhak herzog vient d'être élu
président du pays par les députés une
fonction apolitique qui est largement
cérémoniale aux états unis donald trump
ne s'avoue pas vaincu selon le new york
times le milliardaire aurait confié à
ses proches qu'il s'attendait à être
réinvesti à la présidence cet été une
situation qui s'expliquerait par un
audit non-officiel dans l'arizona ou un
hypothétique nouveau recours devant la
cour suprême
rien de prévu
dans la constitution en tout cas pour le
monde la fin du port du masque en
extérieur se fera de manière
différenciée sur le territoire annonce
des manuels macron le président qui
confirme que la vaccination sera ouverte
aux 12-18 ans à partir du 15 juin
si la situation sanitaire continue de
s'améliorer l'évolution du virus est
malgré tout défavorable en occitanie et
en nouvelles aquitaine
[Musique]
il avait été annulée l'année passée en
raison de la pandémie le forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg ouvre
ses portes ce mercredi et jusqu'au 5
juin un forum sous contraintes
sanitaires pendant trois jours
entrepreneurs diplomates ou encore
responsables politiques vont participer
à des discussions et des débats
notre correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
et sur place plus d'une centaine
d'événements en quatre jours le forum
économique de saint pétersbourg après
une pause l'année dernière due à la
pandémie revient en grande pompe avec
comme thème l'économie de la nouvelle
réalité
l'événement phare de la vie économique
russe a dû lui aussi se plier aux
restrictions sanitaires et des
restrictions y en a beaucoup chacun de
5000 participants du forum a dû passer
un test de détection du coronavirus qui
doit être négatif pour activer leur
badge d'entrée partout sur le forum sont
installés des capteurs thermiques qui
bloque les badges des personnes ayant
une température trop élevée
de manière générale nous avons
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus d'expérience
et de ressources pour assurer la
stabilité de la situation
épidémiologique à saint pétersbourg
je suis convaincu que nous serons
assurer la sécurité pendant le forum
économique international de saint
pétersbourg la sécurité pour les
participants
comme pour les habitants de la ville
personne ne pourra se rendre au forum
sans test pcr négatif
la carte d'accréditation ne marchera pas
aux postes de passage
le moment fort de ce forum c'est
traditionnellement sa session plénière
cette année y participent le chancelier
autrichien sébastien courte et l'émir du
qatar tamim ben hamad al thani qui
seront en vidéo conférence le président
russe vladimir poutine quant à lui
viendra prendre la parole en personne le
sujet est déterminée par le forum
traditionnellement au forum les discours
porte sur les questions sociales et
économiques
celle du développement social et
économique du pays de l'attrait des
investissements etc
le président est en train de rédiger son
discours
le forum économique de saint pétersbourg
et le premier forum d'affaires de grande
ampleur à se tenir en présentiel
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire la
réussite ouverte délégations venues du
monde entier à condition bien sûr que
chacun soit négatif au coronavirus et
pour parler de ce forum économique
organisé tous les ans par la russie nous
retrouvons jean marc sylvestre notre
envoyé spécial sur place bonsoir vos
remarques
merci d'être avec nous quels sont les
enjeux de ce forum on le rappelle un
verrat vient nous dire longuement qui a
lieu évidemment en pleine pandémie
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ces familles vous savez le
premier enjeu c'est pour la russie de
montrer qu'elle est capable de mettre en
place les conditions de rigueur et de
protection alors nous sommes donc tous
passés par les épreuves que vera nous
décrivait à savoir le test à l'arrivée
de l'aéroport et puis leur test aussi
dont on aura le résultat dans la nuit
pour pouvoir accéder aux salles de
réunion de ce forum de saint pétersbourg
ce forum de saint pétersbourg est
considéré comme le rival de davos davos
a été annulé pendant deux ans et bien en
russie on voulait sans doute montré
qu'on était capable qu'il fallait se
remettre au travail et très vite parce
qu'il s'agit bien de travail saint
pétersbourg c'est un forum de business
il y avait certes un certain nombre de
chefs d'états d'âme de gouvernement mais
il y a beaucoup d'industriels beaucoup
de financiers beaucoup de banquiers ils
viennent ici pour discuter discuter de
contrats faire des projets faire des
projets d'investissement et faire des
affaires
alors si les conditions sont un peu
particulières je crois que les officiels
de la russie ont voulu aussi montrer
qu'il était capable de faire taire un
soupçon de laxisme qui planait un peu
dans le monde occidental par rapport aux
conditions de protection et c'est vrai
que dans cette nuit magique des
véhicules a pour la première fois à
saint pétersbourg ses nuits blanches
là le port du masque n'est pas forcément
porté avec beaucoup de détermination par
ailleurs on sait que
la vaccination la campagne de
vaccination a un peu de mal à se
développer donc c'est tout ça que le
forum de de saint pétersbourg a voulu
marquer l'entrée dans une nouvelle
époque l'entrée posco vide
jean-marc pour autant il y a du monde
qui a répondu présent quels sont les
acteurs sur place
eh bien écoutez la plupart des grands
industriels des grands financiers de la
planète se sont déplacés où on envoyait
un certain nombre de leurs
correspondants ou de leurs
collaborateurs
on a ici beaucoup de représentants
d'amérique du sud et même d'amérique du
nord
les représentants africains bien sûr du
continent asiatique
et puis des européens ce sont des chefs
d'état il y en a certains ce sont des
hommes d'état y en a aussi mais ce sont
surtout les chefs d'entreprise qui
viennent ici je vous le disais tout à
l'heure pour faire des affaires parce
qu'il ya des projets et compte tenu des
nouvelles conditions économiques qui se
profile après ce qu vide compte tenu des
changements de rapports de force qui
peuvent exister dans le monde
il est évident qu'il ya quantité de
projets de développement projets
d'investissement dans des nouveaux
secteurs notamment la technologie
notamment le digital notamment
l'écologie qui sont en train de s'ouvrir
et qui font des appels à la fois de fond
de compétences et d'intelligence ce qui
retient l'attention jean marc sylvestre
c'est que on le voit sur le plan
géopolitique c'est pas toujours l'amour
fou entre les parties les pays
occidentaux et la russie est pourtant
sur le plan économique tout semble plus
fluide
business le jeu elle sait j'ose dire
oui alors vous avez totalement raison
c'est vrai qu'il ya un climat ici est
parfois un peu lourd à porter parce que
la russie subit un certain nombre de
sanctions ça ne gêne à la page et n'est
pas trop le commerce et et les flux de
financement occidentaux le coc vide a
beaucoup plus creuser les fossés entre
ceux qui pouvaient travailler ceux qui
ne le pouvait pas mais ceci étant ici on
est quand même très pragmatique pour
considère qu' il y as d'un côté c'est la
politique et la politique ce sont des
rapports de force la politique ce sont
parfois des conflits des avis divergents
mais que par ailleurs il y à l'économie
et l'économie
ce sont des contrats c'est du solide
c'est du travail ce sont des
investissements et des emplois
et ça aussi bien du côté russe que du
côté occidental aussi bien dans les
entreprises françaises ou européennes
que dans les entreprises qui sont liées
à la russie on va tout faire pour
protéger les capacités de développement
parce qu'ils sont facteur de progrès ils
sont facteurs de faire merci jean marc
sylvestre en direct de saint pétersbourg
pour ce forum qu'on suivra évidemment
avec vous
[Musique]
itzhak herzog et le nouveau président
d'israël ancien chef du parti
travailliste il remplacerait vénerie
blain rivlin à cette fonction largement
honorifique
il a été élu ce matin par les députés en
pleine crise politique et alors que dans
quelques heures prendra fin l'ultimatum
pour former un nouveau gouvernement de
coalition
les tractations se joue notamment entre
le parti centriste et le parti d'extrême
droite un accord tournerait la page de
l'ère netanyahu sans accord les
israéliens devront retourner aux urnes
pour la cinquième fois en moins de deux
ans yamina benguigui benyamin nétanyahou
vie peut être les dernières heures de
son règne après 12 ans à la tête
d'israël
hier soir encore les négociations
battent leur plein entre les partis de
la coalition destinée à le faire tomber
après l'accord scellé dimanche entre
yaïr lapid leader du parti centriste et
naftali bennet chef de file de l'extrême
droite
l'heure est à l'ouverture aux autres
partis même les plus éloignés sur
l'échiquier politique
ce gouvernement ne peut fonctionner que
si nous travaillons ensemble en tant que
groupe
pas moi mais nous tous les partis sont
invités à rejoindre la coalition
chaque partie de cette coalition a un
pouvoir de vote similaire et chaque
parti aura un droit de veto alors que la
perspective d'une alternative à
netanyahou se dessine l'ancien ministre
des finances yaïr lapid reste prudent il
y encore beaucoup d'obstacles avant la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
c'est peut-être une bonne chose car nous
devrons les surmonter ensemble
si notre premier test voir si nous
pouvons trouver des compromis
intelligent dans les jours qui viennent
pour atteindre le but le plus important
mais pour benyamin nétanyahou qui défend
ardemment sa place cette coalition est
un danger imminent pour les israéliens
je lance un appel à mes amis qui ont été
élus sur des électeurs de droite ceux
qui ont une conscience et des valeurs ne
formaient pas un gouvernement de gauche
ce gouvernement est une menace pour la
sécurité d'israël est pour l'avenir de
ce pays
sac à main comme tout l'enjeu pour les
différents partis de cette coalition
anti
netanyahu est de s'entendre sur la
répartition des ministères notamment
ceux très convoité de la défense et de
la justice
autre enjeu majeur l'union nationale et
la place de la communauté arabe dans un
pays qui sort à peine d'un nouveau
conflit avec le hamas et où cette
communauté représente 20% de la
population
les regards se tournent vers les deux
parties arabes ram et la liste unie
voici ce que le leader du parti raam
disait encore hier alors qu'il
participait aux dernières négociations
sur la coalition tant que ce n'est pas
fini
rien n'est décidé avec ce rapprochement
en devenir
les analystes politiques laissent
entrevoir un possible apaisement entre
les communautés arabes et juives
en attendant les israéliens seront dès
aujourd'hui si la coalition lapide
bennett tient la route ou s'ils devront
retourner aux urnes
et pour plus de précisions nous
retrouvons tout de suite police ailleurs
journaliste pour rt internationale en
direct de tel-aviv bonsoir fola merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
donc les adversaires de bmi netanyahu
ans jusqu'à minuit pour parvenir à un
accord leur ai donc on l'imaginé aux
dernières tractations
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur ces négociations
[Musique]
les chefs de l'opposition et rapide
jusqu'à geler d'israël tantôt heures
afin de dire au président israélien s'il
est en position ou pas de former un
gouvernement de majorité pour le moment
ce que cela laisse toujours pas clair
nous avons récemment reçu des rapports
disant qu'un politicien 2 7 et 2 go sion
de majorité comme s'est retiré la
coalition recouvre 61 sur 120 sièges
parlementaires
une seule défection signifierait
la perte de la majorité et
l'impossibilité de former un
gouvernement de majorité ou les très
difficiles à se prononcer pour le moment
depuis plusieurs heures et il ya des
rencontres en parler ça entre des
politiciens qui concocte des accords
secrets de plus aujourd'hui on a
également beaucoup parlé de la questure
de aïcha kate c'est le numéro deux du
parti
yamina yamina et signifie aile droite et
c'est le parti de la droite de
l'échiquier politique israélien dirigé
par naftal ib la tâche elle souhaite
être chargé de la sélection des juges de
la cour suprême
un autre politicien s'y opposent du
parti travailliste
donc il y a beaucoup de tractations et
on ne sait encore pas vraiment ce qu'il
va arriver à cette heure paula sont
offerts dans la voyant entrer dans la
boule de cristal qu'elle pourrait être
l'issue la plus probable
chaque heure change je vous aurais dit
qu'il est beau je vous dirais coup pour
le moment qu'à 70% il n'y aura pas de
gouvernement de coalition
il ya deux heures je vous aurais dit
exactement le contraire que à 70%
j'étais certain qu'il y aurait un
gouvernement de coalition
donc c'est très difficile de se
prononcer le grand problème ce que nous
ne savons pas quels sont les accords les
promesses complet par exemple en cat ont
promis aux affaires du parti arabe ram à
ses soutiens faisait partie de la
coalition
et expliquer que des politiques de la
droite pourrait se retirer de la
coalition ce qui signifierait que trop
de faveur ou d octroyer aux partis
arabes ce n'est qu'un exemple des
nombreuses transactions en cours et la
déclaration il doit se faire dans moins
de deux heures avant l'échéance de
minuit si le chef de l'opposition hier
la pid
il ne peut pas dire aux précédents et
sera et lien qui elle a réussi à former
un gouvernement de coalition majoritaire
alors le problème va se retrouver devant
le parlement israélien et les
parlementaires ton le problème du
actuelle benyamin nétanyahou auront
plusieurs semaines afin d'essayer de
former une coalition majoritaire mais
cela semble peu probable et il y aura
peut-être plus tôt sans doute de
nouvelles sections la quatrième élection
espace de deux ans justement en vue de
l'extérieur pour là on a le sentiment
que ce scénario se filmer rejouer très
régulièrement en ifren etc
finalement à chaque fois et bien c'est
benyamin nétanyahou qui gagne tout à
fait vrai c'est la même perception sont
les israéliens au sein du ca soutient
l'appel le magicien car il semble
toujours réussir à revenir at your
pouvoir donc il faudrait faire attention
avant et exclure cette possibilité
il est impossible de dire à ce stade si
l'opposition pourra annoncer une
majorité avant minuit et même si
l'opposition y réussit alors cela ne
suffit pas que banny montagne où va se
retirer
c'est le premier ministre de l'histoire
d'israël qui a gouverné le plus
longtemps et même s'il ne gagne pas il
pourrait passer à l'opposition et
devenir chef de l'opposition et même
dans cette position s'il y avait un
nouveau gouvernement
alors ce gouvernement serait composé de
sept partis politiques très différents
des partis de droite des partis de
gauche qui ont très peu de choses en
commun leur seul point commun c'est
qu'ils souhaitent le départ de taye
netanyahu et même dans un scénario idéal
ce gouvernement si il réussit à être en
forme et pourrait ne durer que quelques
mois
il y aurait donc de nouvelles élections
et s'il ya de nouvelles élections en
israël benyamin fanion aura de nouveau
une chance de retrouver son poste le
premier ministre nous que le magicien
déploie ses sortilèges les il est
inquiet et lui aussi organise beaucoup
de rencontres fait beaucoup de promesses
à des politiciens afin de les encourager
à rejoindre son camp et non pas celui de
l'opposition
merci mon coppola flyers journée nice
portée internationale en direct
tel aviv n'est évidemment au courant de
la suite des événements merci à vous et
pour approfondir sur ce sujet nous
sommes avec abondance maison expert en
relations internationales
bonsoir peau de blanche saison merci
d'être avec nous ont vraiment parlé avec
paul à cette crise qui ne cesse de finir
en israël pourquoi cette crise qui dure
maintenant depuis deux ans même cela
signifie sans doute que la magie
netanyahu ne fonctionne plus comme
auparavant en israël benjamin netanyahu
est au pouvoir depuis 12 ans et sans
discontinuer il avait été premier
ministre pendant trois années
dans la décennie précédente et pendant
les dix premières années deux de ses
douze ans à chaque fois son parti le
likoud est arrivé en tête et il a pu
former une majorité
ce n'est plus le cas depuis deux années
parce que en effet le régime le régime
israélien est une démocratie
parlementaire et la knesset le parlement
chambre unique à 120 députés
il faut donc avoir soixante et une voix
pour avoir la confiance de cette chambre
et netanyahu y est parvenu avec des
alliances
il faut savoir que les élections se font
au suffrage universel mais à la
proportionnelle et que par conséquent
cela favorise les petits partis
cela favorise même les dissidences des
grands partis et donc il faut négocier
pour constituer une coalition pour
constituer une alliance
il y est parvenu pendant dix ans depuis
deux années eli parvient plus est
effectivement à chaque fois il a préféré
la dissolution retourner devant les
électeurs
plutôt que de courir le risque de voir
quelqu'un d'autre
former un gouvernement alors c'est
exactement où on en est ce soir
le celui qui a été chargé de former le
gouvernement par le président de
d'israël ne parvient pas à 23h59 hé bien
il restera à la knesset soit à proposer
un nouveau formateur au président soit à
recommander la dissolution et c'est
probablement cette dissolution que
monsieur netanyahou souhaite alors
évidemment la formation actuelle la
négociation actuelle qui dure depuis
trois jours est très difficile parce que
comme ça été dit dans votre sujet on y
trouve un parti de droite qui est un
parti nationaliste et religieux mais on
y trouve aussi des partis de centre
gauche était parti de gauche
et puis même probablement un parti
d'arabes israéliens ce qui est une
grande première et ce qui est
probablement le plus étonnant dans dans
ce qui se passe en israël depuis depuis
quelques jours donc on sera tout à
l'heure dans moins de deux heures quelle
est l'issue il est possible que ça
marche parce qu'il ya un vrai désir en
israël en effet de changer et de changer
de premier ministre après toutes ces
années netanyahu mais il n'est pas sûr
que ça fonctionne et dans auquel cas on
aura à nouveau des élections et un
nouveau peut-être une difficulté pour
monsieur netanyahou à former une
majorité
alors admettons si la coalition se
former est ce qu'elle serait viable
selon vous ben on peut en tout cas être
sûr que le likoud s'emploiera à lui
faire une vie difficile et c'est ce que
fait le likoud
actuellement bien entendu cela dit est
évidemment le fait qu'il y ait un
nouveau premier ministre
le fait qu'il y ait le soutien d'un
parti d'israéliens arabe le fait que les
nationalistes religieux est probablement
le poste de premier ministre fera pense
pas fera passer une sorte de vent
nouveau
et probablement pendant un certain temps
ce gouvernement pourra amener des idées
nouvelles
mais il est possible en effet que compte
tenu de ses contradictions internes ne
puisse pas dirigé le pays pendant très
longtemps et où quelqu'un on retournera
devant les électeurs d'ici quelques mois
ou quelques années
et à l'instant que blanche raison le
parti arabe ram fait savoir qu'il
formalise et son appui au projet de
coalition anti netanyahu on verra les
conséquences auxois avoir peut-être dans
la soirée toujours en cas de former 10 /
de formation des coalitions quelles
pourraient être les conséquences sur le
conflit israélo palestinien
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que les
institutions fonctionnent normalement en
israël la knesset a élu tout à fait
normalement comme c'était prévu depuis
longtemps après tir de la république qui
prendra ses fonctions le 9 juillet et ce
président de la république était le
président du parti travailliste
ce président de parti travailliste
monsieur herzog a et connu pour avoir
lorsqu'il est venu prévient le parti
travailliste était rendre visite à
mahmoud abbas tout qu'il le connaît et
il entretient des contacts avec le chef
de l'autorité palestinienne
bien sûr il n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
c'est un président type quatrième
république
mais il a quand même eu une influence et
on peut je pense compter sur lui pour
faire en sorte que le gouvernement
essaie de renouer le dialogue avec
l'autorité palestinienne
alors pour le reste et bien beaucoup
risque de se jouer au caire puisque le
président 6-6 a demandé aux aux deux
parties palestiniennes de venir au caire
le hamas et le fatah de façon à examiner
les conditions d'une réunification des
palestiniens et ceux ci est
effectivement un enjeu considérable
le président si si je crois a joué un
très grand rôle dans le cessez le feu
entre le hamas et israël
et maintenant ils souhaiteraient joue un
rôle important dans la réunification des
palestiniens sous l'autorité de
l'autorité palestinienne mais ceci est
en effet très difficile
merci coach maison expert en relations
internationales
nal aux états unis après ans malgré la
défaite à la présidentielle donald trump
ne savent manifestement pas vaincu et
continue de faire parler de lui même
s'il est bannie de twitter de facebook
et d'instagram depuis l'assaut de ses
partisans contre le capitole le 6
janvier dernier
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite notre reporter sur place thomas
bonnet en direct de washington
bonsoir thomas plus de quatre mois donc
après son départ de la maison blanche
donald trump continue de faire parler de
lui
régulièrement les médias américains
évoquent même la possibilité de son
retour oui la police la possibilité de
quitter son retour est un sujet qui est
très régulièrement discutée dans les
émissions de débat ici aux etats-unis
mais cette fois c'est un tweet d'une
journaliste du new york times qui a
provoqué beaucoup de réactions selon à
maggie habermann l'ex-président
américain aurait confié à des proches
qu'il s'attendait à être réinvesti à la
maison blanche d'ici le mois d'août
un message qui a provoqué la polémique
sur twitter certains reprochant à l'adie
de journalistes de relayer de fausses
informations
il faut dire que ce tweet intervient au
lendemain d'une autre polémique
provoquée par michael flynn l'ancien
conseiller à la sécurité nationale de
donald trump lors d'un meeting
un spectateur lui a demandé pourquoi ce
qui s'est passé en birmanie ne pourrait
pas se produire aux états unis faisant
référence au coup d'état militaire qui
est venu en birmanie
ce à quoi michael flynn a répondu je
cite il n'y a pas de raison ça devrait
avoir lieu alors malgré le rétropédalage
de l'intéressé cette phrase a relancé
les polémiques autour des agissements de
certains des soutiens de donald trump
pour contester le résultat de la
dernière élection présidentielle
alors de son côté thomas l'ancien
président a décidé de s'investir au
centre du parti républicain oui s'il fut
un temps question qu'il crée son propre
parti donald trump semble aujourd'hui
déterminé à garder son influence dans le
parti républicain pour preuve il sera ce
week-end en caroline du nord pour la
convention républicaine de cet état une
étape parmi d'autres puisque donald
trump prévoit d'autres meetings en juin
et en juillet avec pour but est
d'apporter son soutien à ses fidèles et
à se maintenir un cercle influent au
sein du parti républicain
alors selon certains analystes
politiques et l'idée pour donald trump
serait de participer à la réussite des
républicains justement lors des
élections de mi-mandat en 2022 afin
d'arriver en bonne posture pour la
présidentielle de 2000 24 maintenant on
en n'est évidemment pas encore là mais
force est de constater que malgré les
procédures lancées contre lui et malgré
son bannissement des réseaux sociaux
donald trump reste encore très populaire
auprès de sa base selon un sondage ipsos
pour reuters paru en mai seulement 28%
des républicains pensent que donald
trump ne devrait pas se présenter en
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington
elle reste avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du masque
devenus objets de notre quotidien la fin
de son port en extérieur se fera de
manière différenciée sur le territoire
annonce des manuels macron et puis nous
évoquerons la nouvelle calédonie
loyalistes et indépendantistes se sont
mis d'accord à paris pour un nouveau
vote sur l'indépendance avant la fin de
l'année
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
je
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois si demain un conflit ouvert ce
produit entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser il se déroulera dans la
mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux bus 1
en 2019 la chine a construit en une
année temps de paix plus de bâtiments
que les états unis en quatre en guerre
de 1941 à 1940 en affichant ainsi sa
souveraineté en mer de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits
historiques sur les règles
internationales
quand une puissance dominante constate
qu'elle est en train de se faire
dépasser par une puissance émergente la
tentation normale et de la détruire au
plan politique ou militaire avant
qu'elle n'arrive à ses fins
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise et fiable mais
comment peuvent-ils mentir comme des
arracheurs de dents ce point
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
là elle en soi vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui une gauche plus extrêmes
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soit il est
bienvenu en direct sur arte france si
vous nous rejoignez la crise sanitaire
en france est la vaccination qui sera
ouverte aux 12-18 ans à partir du 15
juin emmanuel macron l'a confirmé ce
soir en marge d'un déplacement dans le
lot
le chef de l'état qui s'est montré
optimiste pour l'été tout en appelant
les français à rester prudents face à
des signaux d'alert dans le sud ouest
côté vaccination emmanuel macron s'est
réjoui du fait que près de 50% des
français adultes et déjà reçu une
première dose de vaccin et concernant
les masques à la fin de son corps en
extérieur se fera de manière
différenciée sur le territoire annonce
par ailleurs emmanuel macron une demande
qui va dans le sens de nombreux maires
certaines communes ont d'ailleurs déjà
levé l'obligation de porter dehors
[Musique]
tous les arcachonnais qui ont souhaité
être vaccinées le sont à ce jour
[Musique]
le pragmatisme et la réalité du terrain
font que ce n'est plus une obligation de
porter le masque sur notre territoire
le rôle d'un élu c'est aussi d'être à
l'écouté de sa population
[Musique]
beaucoup de nos concitoyens aimerait
s'affranchir de cette contrainte que
seule la peur du gendarme et d'une
contravention fait encore respectée car
l'impact réel de cette mesure fait débat
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
olivier fabre maire dvd de mazamet dans
le tarn
bonsoir les femmes merci d'être avec
nous certaines communes ont donc un déjà
levé l'obligation de porter le masque
sanitaire dans l'espace public extérieur
on l'a vu est de plus en plus de
municipalités ont formulé la demande
qu'en est il chez vous dans votre
commune du tarn
mais écoutez moi j'ai demandé à la
préfète du département de lever cette
obligation en extérieur puisque sur
notre département sur le temps sur cet
arrêté préfectoral qui s'impose à
l'ensemble des communes donc moi j'ai
entendu ce que me demander mais mes
concitoyens mazamet une ville de dix
mille habitants en un centre de
vaccination qui tourne très bien on
vaccine quasiment 2000 personnes par
semaine donc sur la commune et et au
delà sur l'ensemble du bassin de vie est
donc aujourd'hui un très fort taux de
vaccination et j'ai des gens qui me
disent notamment des retraités qui ont
eu leurs deux injections et kimi ce
monsieur le maire quand on est sur la
place du marché en train de discuter
entre nous on comprend plus tellement
pourquoi il faut qu'en extérieur alors
qu'on est tous vaccinés on continuera à
porter le masque de la demande que j'ai
fait remonter la préfecture mais pour
l'instant avec une réponse qui est une
réponse négative
qu'est ce qu'on vous a donné comme
argument pour l'instant je pense qu'il
ya une croyance ceux de la part des
autorités par rapport au fait qu' il
faut peut-être pas relâcher les efforts
que ya peut-être une une symbolique du
masque qui qui qui donne encore
effectivement des réflexes des réflexes
de distanciation
je constate malgré tout que le taux
d'incidence est très faible sur le
département du tarn
il est inférieur à assen et donc il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui
l'idée ce serait quand même d'être
pragmatique de prendre la situation au
cas par cas au réel on va dire et de
s'adapter
la précaution oui mais la précaution
quand elle est là quand elle est utile
et peut-être laissé la place aujourd'hui
un peu plus de responsabilités si
certains veulent volontairement
continuer à porter le masque pourquoi
pas il y en a probablement mais si ceux
qui sont vaccinés qui sont en extérieur
alors qu'ils ont le risque qu'ils proche
de zéro vol l'enlever il est peut-être
temps de redonner cette liberté à nos
concitoyens alors même qu'on s'est
exprimé sur ce sujet aujourd'hui on ne
fait le match se fera de manière
différenciée sur le territoire en dit le
président de la république vous saluer
une solution pragmatique
oui la différenciation c'est
effectivement une solution qui est
pragmatique puisqu'elle est elle adaptée
à chaque réalité locale il est bien
évident que les densités de population
et les risques de contamination sont
évidemment extrêmement différent selon
que vous trouvez comme jamais dans une
ville de 10000 habitants ou que vous
vous trouvez sur un quai de gare bondée
dans une métropole de deux millions
d'habitants
évidemment le risque n'est pas le même
et et j'espère que ces déclarations
seront suivies d'effet que sur des
critères objectifs
on pourra aller vers cet assouplissement
qui est qui sera aussi une récompense
parce que moi je trouve certaines que
globalement les français et les
habitants de la commune ont très bien
respecter les restrictions qui leur ont
été imposées ils ont été très nombreux à
aller se faire vacciner à prendre
rapidement
rendez vous je crois qu'il faut aussi
pouvoir un retour au delà des ouvertures
de commerces de restaurants de terrasses
pouvoir leur donner cette liberté et
surtout ce sur quoi je veux insister
c'est qu' il ne faut pas comme je ne
souhaite pas que le masque devienne un
standard une référence quelque chose de
normal
le masque est une protection en cas de
pandémie
mais ça ne doit pas devenir un mode
normal de d'expression que de se parler
le visage de cacher le non verbal est
très important lorsqu'on communique on
passe beaucoup de choses par les
attitudes du visage notamment par le
sourire et je crois qu'il faut pouvoir
aussi revenir à entre nous
progressivement tout en gardant de la
sécurité bien sûr mais quand même penser
à revenir à un mode normal de
communication entre entre les îles entre
les citoyens
aujourd'hui clairement acquis de décider
selon vous le citoyen mais en accord
avec les maires que vous êtes
moi je crois que ce serait au maire de
pouvoir prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent pour pour leur commune o'neal
je crois les mieux à même de connaître
les difficultés je crois qu'on est des
gens responsables on l'a prouvé depuis
le début de cette crise
je prends l'exemple sur mazamet fournit
des masques dès le début du mois de mai
l'an dernière qu' il était difficile
d'en trouver parce qu'on a la chance
d'avoir des entreprises qui fabriquent
du textile ici localement et quand les a
sollicités
on a mis tout en oeuvre pour vacciner
rapidement efficacement et ça fonctionne
bien aujourd'hui donc on est des gens
responsables et on est mieux à même d'y
croire de juger de ce que doit être la
situation dans nos communes et puis
après avoir fait ce sont ce jugement ce
bilan en connaissance de cause c'est
aussi de délivrer un message qui est
celui de la liberté et de la
responsabilité moi j'y suis très attaché
je pense qu'il faut aussi tenir ce
discours d'hier voilà vous êtes vacciné
vous avez effectivement c'est cette
démarche là vous ne risquez aujourd'hui
plus grand chose en extérieur vous
pouvez enlever le masque de dire à ceux
qui n'ont pas pu ou pas voulu encore
être vaccinés on n'est pas là pour eux
pour discriminer les uns par rapport aux
autres mais on vous demande
effectivement de peut-être encore
prendre une précaution supplémentaire
par rapport à ceux qui sont vaccinées
donc très largement protégé tenir un
discours de liberté de responsabilité
plutôt que un discours systématiquement
d'interdiction ou de décisions qui
s'imposent uniformément sang se rappelle
aussi la liberté ii
l'individu 65% des français se déclarent
favorables au maintien de l'obligation
du port du masque à l'extérieur selon un
sondage bva publié le 21 mai c'est un
chiffre qui reflète les comportements
selon vous le ressentez dans votre ville
parce que c'est vrai qu'ici ou là voilà
on sent un petit relâchement en ce
moment avec en plus les beaux jours
alors moi je suis très étonné dans le
chiffre 67 % de français qui
souhaiterait continuer à porter le
masque un extérieur
moi c'est pas du tout le retour que j'ai
de mes habitants mais je peux aussi
entendre que la vision des choses soient
différentes entre les habitants des très
grandes agglomérations des très grandes
métropoles où le peut-être la pression
autour de l'épidémie est plus importante
mais moi je ressens absolument pas ça je
ressemblais je ressentirai plus tôt la
proportion inversée avec une très large
volonté des habitants de haut au moins
en tout cas un extérieur pour l'instant
de pouvoir retirer retirer leurs masques
mais je persiste à dire que le port du
masque doit doit rester dans son concept
quelque chose de temporaire et limitée à
une période d'épidémie très forte et en
aucun cas devenir une normalité une
dernière petite question mnm la croyais
à officialiser également ce soir
l'ouverture de la vaccination pour les
12 18 ans dès le le 15 - c'est un sujet
qui fait débat
vous vous placez de de quel côté vous
même
c'est une question épineuse certainement
coûté mon jeu encore une fois je crois
qu'il faut laisser la liberté la liberté
ou aux habitants aux citoyens de se
déterminer
en tout cas nous eux au centre de
vaccination de nos âmes et où les choses
sont très encadrées toujours avec des
professionnels de santé avec des
médecins référents
si les 12 18 ans veulent venir se faire
vacciner dans les semaines ou les mois
qui viennent ils seront les bienvenus
sur la base du volontariat il n'est pas
question d'obliger ou de forcer les gens
à être vaccinés s'ils ne signent le
souhaite pas mais ceux qui le souhaitent
peuvent peuvent l'être dans de très
bonnes conditions
rapidement et efficacement et et c'est
je crois le rôle des deux de très
nombreux maires en france aujourd'hui 2
de veiller à ce que cette vaccination
puisse continuer pour nous faire sortir
de cette crise dont il faut sortir au
plus vite
évidemment merci beaucoup olivier fabre
à maire dvd de mazamet dans le tarn
merci dans l'actualité le coronavirus
qui frappent violemment les pays pauvres
afin de leur venir en aide
l'om est c'est noël jega vie se sont
alliés pour mettre au point le
dispositif kovacs qui vise à fournir des
vaccins au plus grand nombre
le système va d'ailleurs mobilisé 2 4
milliards de dollars supplémentaires
mais ce système semble avoir du plomb
dans l'aisne les explications de julien
euros depuis le mois de décembre
la plupart des pays développés ont saisi
l'opportunité de vacciner leur
population
mais dans certaines régions du monde il
est plus difficile d'avoir accès à la
vaccination
créé par l'organisation mondiale de la
santé et l'alliance globale pour les
vaccins et l'immunisation le système
kovacs entend remédier à cette carence
grâce à l'aide de 190 états donateurs
ainsi que d'autres acteurs comme
l'unicef ou la fondation gates en 2020
plus de 2 milliards de dollars ont été
récoltés par kovacs une somme à laquelle
devrait s'ajouter 4 milliards de dollars
selon une promesse du président
américain joe biden en février dernier
l'objectif de kovacs en termes de
vaccination est de permettre à au moins
20% de la population de chaque pays
d'être vaccinés malgré les promesses de
ses acteurs les livraisons du retard
plus de 330 millions de doses devaient
être distribués d'ici à la fin juin
seulement 77 millions l'ont été pour le
moment la cause de ces retards sort est
lié à la flambée des cas en inde où se
trouve l'un des principaux fabricants du
vaccin astrazeneca
suite à la dernière vague meurtrière le
fabricant a décidé de suspendre ses
exportations
face à ce bilan le ms a demandé aux pays
riches une aide supplémentaire afin
d'obtenir la vaccination de -30 % des
habitants de chaque pays d'ici septembre
pour atteindre cet objectif 250 millions
de personnes doivent être vaccinées
d'ici à quatre mois la direction
l'australie confronté un inquiétant
variant du covin melbourne décide de
prolonger son confinement d'une semaine
l'australie qui a réaffirmé lundi son
intention d'enquêter sur les origines de
la pandémie le récit est signée web
bennani
un tramway qui passe aucun voyageur à
l'horizon des magasins fermés
c'est le triste quotidien de la deuxième
plus grande ville d'australie à
melbourne s'impose une nouvelle semaine
de confinement la deuxième de suite
au delà de melbourne c'est tout l'état
de victoria qui est en alerte face à un
variant du coc vide
décrit par les autorités comme étant
plus transmissible invariants détecté en
inde le meilleur moyen d'arrêter ce
virus est la vaccination mais comme nous
le savons seuls 2 % de notre population
sont entièrement vacciner si nous
laissons ce virus suivre son cours il va
exploser
nous devons l'écraser parce que si nous
ne le faisons pas des gens vont mourir
et pour booster les écoles bars et
restaurants restent donc fermé tout
rassemblement est interdite et le port
du masque est obligatoire prolonger le
confinement
une décision difficile à prendre pour
les autorités locales alors qu'il ya une
semaine des australiens défilé pour
protester contre les nouvelles mesures
de restriction liée à la pandémie
des autorités et on sait mais qui ne
veulent prendre aucun risque
depuis quelques semaines les clusters se
comptent par centaines
plus particulièrement dans les maisons
de retraite la grande majorité des 900
décès dus au corona virus dans le pays
proviennent justement de ces
établissements il y à plus de 50
victorien qui vivent avec le virus en ce
moment mais il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
de milliers d'autres en tant que cas
contacts qui font tout pour assurer la
sécurité de chacun et je veux les
remercier
ça se sache alors on atteint même est
critiqué par l'opposition travailliste
pour le manque de rigueur de son système
de quarantaine pour les visiteurs
étrangers le gouvernement australien
elle est aussi pour la lenteur de sa
compagne de vaccination alors que le
pays compte 25 millions d'habitants un
peu moins de 4 millions de doses ont
pour l'instant été administrés ont coûté
ses réactions d'habitants de melbourne
contraint à nouveau à se confiner
je pense que ça devait arriver
je ne pense pas que le coc vide était
quelque chose on allait se débarrasser
définitivement et surtout pas de sitôt
je pense que le déploiement du vaccin a
probablement été mal faire et ça n'a pas
aidé les choses non plus c'est une
situation regrettable pour les
entreprises mais en même temps nous
concevons que nous devons faire les
choses bien
il faut que les gens fassent le point
qu'il se désintoxique de l'ambiance
qu'ovide vous suivront toutes les règles
que nous devons suivre
nous les soutenons fermement espérons
simplement que nous pourrons rouvrir dès
que possible et reprendre nos activités
il y à une partie de la population qui
peut trouver les temps difficiles
financièrement et mentalement
ces gens ne peuvent pas travailler pour
joindre les deux bouts ou faire face à
leurs obligations
mais oui dans l'ensemble je pense
personnellement que c'est le bon moment
pour nous de faire une pause de prendre
du recul de planifier des choses est de
profiter davantage de la vie au liban
faute de financement le tribunal spécial
est menacé de disparaître et des chargés
de juger les personnes accusées d'avoir
perpétré l'attentât qui avait coûté la
vie à 22 personnes dont l'ancien premier
ministre libanais rafic hariri
c'était en 2005 à beyrouth nouvel
épisode de la violente crise que
traverse le pays dans un rapport publié
hier la banque mondiale affirme qu'il
s'agit de l'une des pires crises au
monde
elle dira le doré avec valentin
carpentier
beyrouth dans le noir ces images datent
de la mi-avril mais traduisent bien la
situation que traverse le pays
rarement depuis le 19e siècle un pays
n'avait connu un tel effondrement de son
économie une situation détaillé par un
rapport accablant publié ce mardi par la
banque mondiale et intitulé le naufrage
du liban top 3 des pires crises
mondiales
la crise économique et financière est
susceptible de se classer parmi les dix
voire les trois épisodes de crises les
plus graves au niveau mondial de pile au
milieu du 19e siècle du très rarement vu
dans l'ère moderne pour un pays qui il
ya encore quelques années il faisait
partie des plus prospères de la région
du moyen-orient et cette dégringolade ne
comporte aucun tourner en clair en vue
selon les termes du rapport puisque la
monnaie a déjà perdu près de 85 % de sa
valeur depuis 2019
plus de la moitié de la population vit
désormais sous le seuil de pauvreté et
souffre d'une chute vertigineuse du
pouvoir d'achat les politiques l'ont
ruiné le liban était le plus beau des
pays
si je pouvais vivre à l'étranger j'irai
vivre avec mes enfants mais je ne peux
pas vivre à l'étranger
j'adore ce pays il n'y a pas d'avenir
pour un jeune dans ce pays il n'ya
d'avenir pour personne albert fun nadal
balade pouvoir quitter ce pays c'est
comme gagner à la loterie et qui
convient à l'étranger vit mieux
croyez-moi on vit mieux hors du liban
plusieurs facteurs ont aggravé la
situation comme l'explosion du port de
beyrouth le 4 août dernier mais aussi la
crise sanitaire
mais le principal problème montré du
doigt par le rapport est celui d'une
mauvaise gestion par l'élite politique
du pays sur les 18 derniers mois le
fonds monétaire international a proposé
son aide mais l'incapacité de la sphère
politique à former un gouvernement ne
permet pas de la recevoir et la crise ne
semble pas près de se dissiper pour le
pays du cèdre
la banque mondiale prévoit que le pib
réel du pays se contracte de 9 5% sur
l'exercice 2021
comme si les 20 3% de 2020 ne suffisait
pas il est décisif pour le sort
institutionnel du territoire en nouvelle
calédonie le troisième référendum
d'autodétermination aura lieu avant la
fin de cette année annonce aujourd'hui
le ministre d outre-mer sébastien
lecornu
une victoire du oui qui permettrait de
préparer l'exercice de sa pleine
souveraineté
en cas de victoire du non il faudra
alors élaboré un nouveau statut pour la
nouvelle calédonie qui devrait être
approuvé par un nouveau référendum
elle est issue d'une semaine de
discussions à paris des élus calédoniens
semble plutôt satisfait c'est la
première fois
elle est pourtant moi je suis le dossier
gardien de but presque 40 ans maman
c'est la première fois que le
gouvernement français s'est autant
investi
à la préparation d'une mission telle que
nous avons vécue aujourd'hui en
mobilisant les ministres en mobilisant
les directions 1016 affaires étrangères
nord mais c'est pour éclairer notre
éclairé louis puisque l'on défendant le
oui voilà en tout cas je suis satisfait
de cela nous nous étions pour des levées
de l'accord jusqu'en 2022 nous sommes
battus comme d'habitude argument contre
argument pour défendre notre position
d'avant décéléré à 90 en 2022 2018
sommiers de villepin le second et le
troisième finalement à l'issue de nos
discussions ce n'est pas laid ce n'est
pas cette option qui a été retenue par
le gouvernement français qui est seul
compétent en la matière organisez d'al
cajon hommes et aurait d'ailleurs fixé
la date
le gouvernement a fixé la date du
prochain référendum le 12 décembre
nous allons nous y tenir ce lien avec la
france il est maintenant selon moi
garantie que le nom l'emportent
évidemment il nous faudra un nouveau
statut faudra changer la constitution il
faudra faire évoluer notre relation avec
avec la métropole mais et puis maintenir
le droit à l'autodétermination pour que
les indépendantistes ne perdent pas bien
sur l'aspiration qui est la leur
politique et si c'est un oui cela même
manière et on peut pas imaginer non plus
une calédonie qui se détache de la
france ce serait si c'est souhaité par
personne à commencer par moi mais je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on peut aussi se
dire sur la nationalité sur les
compétences régaliennes sur sur des
transferts il y a des discussions aussi
qui peuvent permettre de maintenir ce
lien
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes avec david khalifa
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station mir ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans bienvenue à novossibirsk
nous sommes au bord de la volga le plus
long fleuve d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour à ba et là on est alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernière fois que l'emprunt c'était en
elle me demande pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui peuplaient